so with mathematicians solve a problem
they don't really stop they try to
generalize it they try to create new
games new problems and see if they're
solvable or not so in this case we can
play beyond the game in two different
directions well we had initially three
clones correct in this configuration we
can change the configurations we can for
instance do the simplest thing possible
start with one clone in the first cell
so that's one way change the initial
clones configuration another way to
change the game is change the initial
barbed fence change what the prison is
so let's try the simplest possible game
which is not trivial
so what would that game be same prison
is before three cells but only one clone
is this game possible or impossible now
you can start calculating invariant sums
this that but really why don't you try
to play the game plate maybe it will be
possible because if you can show me one
way to do it then you don't need to show
me anything else I will be convinced
all right so play play play and in fact
just about anything you try here in this
game should work again you have to play
by the rules alright so we have five
clones out and the prison is empty so
this game is solvable and we move on to
the next one but now we large the prism
we make it a nice bigger shape with six
cells can you escape this prison again
you start playing play play play but
after a while and you stop the video and
you play it for ten minutes right okay
you may conjecture that it is impossible
to free the clones so we're back to
square zero trying to figure out why
this is impossible however we have some
progress made from the previous game
because the rules of the game have not
changed therefore you can use exactly
the same invariant as before we just
have to make different calculations with
it we again want to free the clown's
into Greenland let's see if we have
enough gasoline enough wait there
the initial prison Sam if you calculate
it will be 2 and 3/4 the Greenland Sam
will be 1 in a quarter but let's not
forget that the initial Sam is just 1
because we have only 1 clown in one cell
in the first cell so is this a
contradiction
the initial sum is equal to the final
sum that's one and that's less than what
we have in Greenland whoo it's good
really what did it prove it proved that
we have enough weight in Greenland to
free the clowns but did we really free
the clowns did we show a way to do it we
didn't reach a contradiction and we
didn't find a way to free the clowns so
we really are still back to the very
beginning we have to do something more
subtle if we still believe it's
impossible to free the clowns and the
subtler argument comes from a very
simple observation so as we are playing
the game let's watch what happens on Row
1 just on Row 1 I started with 1 clone
there after one move I have another
clone just one I can make another move
and I will again have one clone there I
can make lots of other moves here that
don't change anything but the moment I
try to change something on the first row
I'll be replacing one clone there with
one clone so we are talking about the
first row and at any point during the
game there will be exactly one clone
there and you can check this with
experimenting and symmetrically there
would be exactly one clown in the first
column so really they are restrictions
in Greenland you cannot have for example
two clones like this or perhaps three
clowns like that this is impossible you
must have exactly
one clown in the first row and in the
first column let's see how this changes
our calculations so if you free the
prison the largest contribution in
Greenland from the first row will be 1/8
because this is the first cell after the
prison with the largest weight you
cannot have anything else here or else
you will have a smaller contribution so
on the table this is precisely position
four and from the first column the
largest contribution will be made by
having the clone right here also in
position four let's see what the
calculations show us now we have the
prison and we disappear all of the
clowns beyond the fourth cell in the
first row and in the first column
because their contribution is less than
1/8 and we cannot have two clones there
so let's start adding up how much did we
subtract in other words how much are
those tails that we took away well they
are another geometric series starting
with 1/16 also with ratio 1/2 and if you
use our formulas from before a similar
reasoning you will end up with 1/8 so
those green tails that we took out a
precisely 1/8 each what does this do to
Greenland sum the total sum of the whole
table - the prison Sam - details total
sum for prison some two and three
quarters in 1/8 for each of the cells
this is one now is this a contradiction
it looks very similar to the situation
from the previous problem where we just
squeezed in a contradiction
so the initial sum is 1 we have one
clone in the first cell like that the
final sum has to be one but how am I
going to get one out of this whole table
once again I have to populate every
single cell in Greenland except for the
two tails but that means again
I need to have infinitely many columns
in the end and this is a finite game
therefore again we reach a contradiction
we cannot free the prison pretty cool is
that the end well you can play the game
with large and larger prisons or perhaps
with more clones in different
configurations but as you can see the
problem becomes hard and harder once you
start changing the shape of the prison
or changing the clones configuration why
are we doing this because it's fun once
you solve a particular problem the
original one which in itself was so much
fun you don't stop there you don't want
to stop the fun mathematicians have
found the whole time especially when
they're doing research that's why
they're into this profession they love
it but you'll get you get paid like
people are paying you money
you're just being paid to have fun